[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ses points de vue ravi de
vous retrouver pour une nouvelle
émission qui est aussi la première de
cette semaine puisque on est lundi ça
vous aura pas échappé
on a quatre sujets qu'on a choisi pour
exprimer et pourrait changer surtout des
points de vue d'abord cette violence en
banlieue qui n'en finit pas avec un
nouvel un nouveau pas franchi ce
week-end c'est un enfant de 12 ans qui
est mort suite à une rixe entre bandes
ça se passait aux lilas donc dans le
département de seine-saint-denis est ce
qu'on peut encore faire quelque chose ou
est ce qu'il est trop tard on en parlera
nous parlerons aussi de l' influence des
juges dans la vie politique notamment
parce que marine le pen a été mise en
examen une nouvelle fois vendredi
dernier puis vous écouterez déclarations
de françois bayrou ce dimanche au grand
jury
il trouve lui que peut-être les juges
ont un impact trop important sur la vie
politique en tout cas c'est ce qu'il
sous-entend nous parlons aussi de
l'assemblée nationale l'assemblée
nationale est elle devenue un lieu pour
les happenings la france insoumise et le
spécialiste de sa notamment françois
ruffin et lui au moins il assume oui
c'est vrai l'assemblée ça sert aussi à
faire des coups d'éclat
et puis nous parlerons de cette
proposition de anne hidalgo la maire de
paris c'était dans le journal du
dimanche d'hier d'accueillir des sdf à
la mairie est ce que c'est une bonne
idée ou est ce que c'est de la démagogie
on en parlera avec nos quatre invités
bonsoir elisabeth lévy ravis de vous
accueillir vous êtes la directrice de la
rédaction de causeur votre magazine qui
met eric zemmour en couverture de son
dernier numéro
pour parler de la censure une insulte à
la france vous êtes aussi l'auteur entre
autres des riens pensant ouvrage publié
aux éditions du cerf alexis poulin et là
aussi bonsoir vous est le cofondateur du
média en ligne le monde moderne point
médias vous avez été chroniqueur sur le
média qui s'appelle le média est proche
de la france insoumise
vous en avez été viré pour dérive
droitière je suis parti tout seul
bonjour des rendements internes au parti
socialiste de toute façon sur ce plateau
c'est assez moi je la fais toujours
c'est important l'autocritique tout le
monde l'a fait pas malheureusement voilà
à frédéric dabi et là aussi bon soir
frédéric gonseth politologue directeur
général adjoint de l'ifop et alexandre
devait que nous a rejoints merci
alexandre vous êtes journaliste aux
pages débats opinion du figaro vous êtes
surtout le responsable du figaro vox cet
espace de liberté de débat et d'opinion
qui régale notamment le figaro magazine
chaque semaine d'interviews passionnante
votre dernier livre les nouveaux enfants
du siècle a été publié aux éditions du
cerf
je vous le disais samedi une bagarre
une rixe a opposé deux bandes de seine
saint denis avec des adolescents des
enfants même notamment un enfant de 12
ans originaire de bagnolet qui est mort
à la suite de cette mouvement violent
cinq mineurs ont été mises en examen
après 7 après cette bagarre est ce qu'on
peut faire quelque chose encore pour
lutter contre cette violence
écoutez ce qu'en pense alexis corbière
il est député la france insoumise
justement de seine-saint-denis là où ça
s'est passé et pour lui ben il faut plus
de moyens plus d'argent regardez c'était
ce matin sur rtl que les gens sachent
que bagnols et n'a pas de commissariat
de plein exercice
ça veut dire qu'à 18 heures la petite
antenne de police et fermé c'est à dire
que le commissariat d situé aux lilas et
qui couvre une zone de près de 800
hectares
les policiers font ce qu'ils peuvent il
n'y a pas assez de moyens est ce que
tout le monde sait que le tribunal de
bobigny est totalement saturé pour
divorcer en grand à bobigny vous mettez
18 mois à paris vous mettez six mois
avant de parler durcissement s comment
on peut travailler normalement est ce
que les juges peuvent travailler
normalement ils ne le peuvent pas alors
discours assez classique finalement sur
le sur le manque de moyens
écoutez c'est maintenant ce point de vue
qui est un peu différent c'est celui de
grégory goupil c'est le secrétaire
régional du syndicat de police alliance
toujours en seine saint denis pour louis
oui bien sûr on manque de moyens mais il
ya peut-être aussi une justice qui n'est
pas assez sévère
regarde bien sûr il nous faudrait du
monde après on peut pas mettre un
policier derrière chaque gamin la
justice demande également
les moyens et qui n'ont pas les moyens
de travail écrit faut leur donner aussi
des moyens parce que décidé policiers
travaillent et qui a pas une réponse
pénale adaptée par une surcharge de la
population carcérale
parce que il ya plein de choses qui
empêche à m'ont donné une condamnation
ferme
on a un sentiment d'impunité chez les
moins de 18 ans ils font des
allers-retours au tribunal et qui
ressorte libre elisabeth lévy est ce
qu'on peut encore lutter contre 7 ans
sauvagement d'une partie de nuit et
alors il faut dire quand même que face à
l'état face à la police face à l'école
parce que là on parle que d'eux mais
l'école est quand même aussi concernés
eh ben il ya des ennemis très puissant
parce que vienne culture de la violence
quand même qui s'est développée à un
point qu'on n'a probablement du mal à
mesurer je ne sais pas si on ne
surestimons pas mais par exemple dans
l'une il lui l'univers du rap est quand
même à bayonne avec tout toute cette
affaire on dit ah oui c'est une bagarre
entre bandes certes mais c'est un
univers où la violence est omniprésente
donc à quand même il ya des
et des forces contraires des portes qui
encouragent la violence etc et
nourrissent la violence très peur ce
n'est plus tout seul que je ne vais pas
énumérer ici
et face à ça je voudrais donner un
exemple qui va au delà des institutions
ciblé parce que je pense que les
policiers ont tout à fait raison sur la
justice il ya un gros problème mais
rappelez vous quand un chauffeur
d'autobus
il n'y a pas longtemps je sais pas où ça
s'est passé il ya un gamin probablement
même pas pas forcément bien menée par un
gamin insolent et inconscients qui
manque de se faire renverser au gourou
le regarde pas du tout parce qu'il doit
avoir son téléphone sur les sons
écouteurs son casque sur les oreilles ou
un truc dans ce moulin le est une
insulte le chauffeur lequel excédé lui
en colle une hélas si vous voulez alors
que tout le monde devrait dire très bien
c'est à dire on peut pas le matin d'hier
il faut de l'autorité et ensuite si vous
les enquiquiner le moindre flic qui font
une taloche grand gamin on va pas sous
les eaux on est complète le chauffeur de
bus a été suspendue une journée mais
suspendu de ses exactement la même chose
que les flics si vous moulin qui dès
qu'ils sont plutôt on est plutôt
encouragés à ne rien faire à ne pas
réagir
c'est la même chose que les profs
combien de profs nous ont raconté que et
que rappelez-vous ce proviseur qui en a
fait un bouquin combien de profs nous en
raconter quand c'est pas le proviseur
qui leur dit on veut pas dans merde fait
pas de vagues et cetera
c'est le rectorat donc il ya il y alors
ça je pense que ça change un peu en
matière d'école mais déjà y ait une
culture si vous voulez un peu de
tolérance dont la société nourri par
l'exclusivisme par le confessionnalisme
par les pauvres petits sont des victimes
ces criminels de leur mettre dans la
tête qu'ils sont des victimes
alexis poulain elisabeth lévy music en
gros ce genre de drame c'est le reflet
d'une forme de laxisme généralisé de la
société de manque d'autorité vous êtes
d'accord
oui c'est c'est la faillite de l'état
d'ailleurs même
donnez pas seulement l'état pour moi
c'est à la fois l'éducation la sécurité
tout ce qui est des services publics
tout ce qui fait aussi qu'on fait du
lien vous avez ces quartiers là il ya
quelques années eric zemmour en parle
dans son livre vous aviez du lien vous
aviez eu des mjc des clubs de foot
quelque chose qui faisait que les gens
pouvaient se rencontrer qui avait aussi
une melting potes des cultures
aujourd'hui c'est monoculturel
aujourd'hui vous le dites c'est la
culture de la violence qui fait qui fait
la loi
quand vous avez la rixe non mais qui
aidait à tenir un peu à faire du lien ce
qui manque aujourd'hui symbole des
nations était à peine un gamin de 12 ans
qui se fait massacrer par des gamins qui
ont de même à l'ag c'est catastrophique
bien sûr nous on arrive là et je veux
bien qu'il ait pas effectivement on
manque de moyens de police mais c'est
pas la réponse n est pas que sécuritaire
comment ces gamins là on arrive à avoir
une éducation qui n'existent pas parce
que à 12 ans on n'est pas à ce moment-là
capable de telles violences
si ça se passait dans le passé c'était
il ya eu la guerre des boutons des
choses comme ça là on parle de la guerre
des boutons la kalachnikov c'est comme
ça qu'est ce qu'on croit la garde sa
part dit les bancs de gauche y en a
toujours eu mais qu'on arrive à ce degré
de violence entre gosse là ça pose un
problème est que ce soit dans des
quartiers où normalement on pourrait
calmer on pourrait dire mais que font
les gens ils descendent pas de chez eux
parce qu'on n'ose pas parce que tout le
monde a peur parce que derrière ça vous
avez quand vous êtes un secouriste vous
devez mettre un gilet pare-balles
concept à pompiers vous prenez des
machines à laver qui tombe du toit et
quand vous êtes un policier vous y allez
plus parce que vous avez peur et vous
aviez la police de proximité
éventuellement parce qu'on vous donne
pas le nom mais qui ne va pas parce
qu'il aborde maintenant mais les
policiers quand même rappeler rond
rappelez vous c'était quand à
grand-place khamis de l'intérieur y
aller en faisant une grande descente
présent va nettoyer à grenoble grand
place grenoble s'ennuie aujourd'hui
c'est à peu près un coup de couteau par
semaine donc ça n'a rien changé je
voulais vous dire c'est l'alternance qui
empêcherait policière y aller c'est le
fait qu'on leur donne pas d'ordre pour
le faire c'est ne vont pas d'ordre et je
pense qu'on a un peu dépassé aussi par
un moment où effectivement la république
et hors les murs et on peut plus y aller
c'est des quartiers qui sont roue libre
je comprends que
vous contribuiez plus aux médias vous
n'êtes pas exactement sa souris sur la
pression parce que les gens se
souviennent secteur est élevé mais le
principe de l'état et la caisse elle
touche tout le monde et les premiers
invités sont excusés - sk pas à gauche
quand même un déni des cultures elle
même un peu moi ça commence à se
réveiller martine aubry quand même qui a
sorti cette phrase on n'imaginait pas ça
il ya un an quick et câline il faut
davantage de policiers parce que on est
plus en république ça ira mieux quand
c'est plus des consciences a mis plus de
temps à gauche peut-être voilà on attend
on attend juste un millier de
l'intérieur désiré dernier sa bague
alors moi ce qui me frappe c'est que
l'enjeu de la sécurité revient de
manière très forte en force dans le
discours des français c'est qu'enfin
quelques mois il avait été phagocyté par
la question aux terroristes quand on
interrogeait et fonçait sur les
questions sécuritaires
il répondait lutte contre le terrorisme
on voit que les cheveux la question
sécuritaire revient très fortement les
français par de plus en plus
d'impuissance des pouvoirs publics il ya
eu toute une litanie de faits divers
rappelez-vous en isère parce que vous en
parliez de la sphère d'adrien perez au
cours de l'été dernier par rapport à ce
que disait elizabeth sur la gauche qui
n'auraient pas fait peut-être qu'il
n'aurait pas fait autant de chemin moi
je suis frappé quand j'interroge les
français sur les questions sécuritaires
à quel point l'équivalent se sont afin
d'y pendant très longtemps les questions
sécuritaires c'était plus fortement
portés par les personnes âgées par les
sympathisants de droite là c'est un
cetain c'est une c'est une c'est une
inquiétude généralisée avec bien sûr une
intensité plus grande dimension
la difficulté de lagos à prendre en
compte la dimension culturelle alors
cultures annuelles avec une dimension
plus forte avec une une expression de la
sécurité et culturel plus forte à droite
et chez et au rassemblement national et
ce qui me frappe aussi c'est le
sentiment qui est exprimée çà et là
c'est ainsi halphen mais ça peut monter
que nos enfants ne sont plus en sécurité
pendant très longtemps au coeur de
l'angoissé des parents c'est une
angoisse sociale c'était un pessimisme
de projection mes enfants vivront moins
bien dans le monde
de demain que moi et là deux de plus en
plus cette antienne est rattachée à la
question de leur sécurité il ya vraiment
une alerte havas le fait qu'ils aient
pas de ministre de l'inde de l'intérieur
depuis fin mai après ministre depuis
maintenant une quinzaine de jours
n'arrange pas les choses
alors on va demander l'avis de
l'élection de vecchio bien sûr mais
avant cela le point de vue des
internautes vous réagissez bien sûr
comme à chaque émission sur twitter sur
lefigaro.fr
voici quelques points de vue celui
d'andy mckee nous dit la seule solution
est là c'est plus de répression
mian qui propose d'envoyer l'armée ça
dépend aussi anecdotique qu'il y paraît
on se souvient d'une sénatrice
socialiste de marseille qui disait la
même chose pour les quartiers nord de sa
ville adrien qui pensent que le système
n'a pas la volonté car sinon tout cela
aurait été réglé depuis longtemps
c'est une question de conviction nous
dit il tandis que tweets se désole la
situation est dramatique
alexandre ii vecchio voilà la question
c'est est ce qu'on peut encore faire
quelque chose et comme le constat est
très a été très bien dressés jusque là
oui je pense que effectivement il ya
quand même des des mesures à prendre
qu'on a qu'on n'a pas pris notamment on
a été effleurée par le syndicat de
police mais en terme de justice il faut
que toute la chaîne pénale fonctionne et
effectivement si on met des gens en
prison sert à rien s'ils ressortent deux
jours après après si on peut pas mettre
les mineurs en prison n'a parlé d'
autorité tout à l'heure je crois que
l'autorité dans la société il faut il en
faut à l'école par exemple mais ça
suffit pas il en faut aussi chez les
parents et donc je pense que pour
responsabilité de responsabiliser les
parents il faut peut-être pas hésité à
les punir dans ce genre de cas qu'on
sait des mineurs qui sont concernés les
élus là qui aujourd'hui se se plaignent
de ne pas avoir assez de moyens alors
c'est vrai qu'en seine-saint-denis je
trouve qu'il ya pas assez de policiers
par rapport aux besoins
mais pourrait instaurer une sorte de
couvre-feu si dans leur ville il ya des
bandes de mineurs que qui s'affrontent à
partir d'une certaine heure on peut
imaginer cela et enfin juste un mot sur
gérard collomb qui a qui a dit autrefois
enfin aujourd'hui on vit côte-à-côte
j'ai peur que demain on vive face à face
il a dit autre chose qu'on a moins ou
démissionner notionnels du ministère de
l'intérieur c'était un peu son testament
il a ajouté notre phrase qui a été moins
relayée
qui était en matière d'immigration il
est revenu sur sa loi asile et
immigration il faut prendre notre part
mais surtout surtout il faut arrêter de
mettre des immigrés dans ces quartiers
qui sont déjà ghettoïser donc je pense
que c'est l'un des tabous de ce sujet là
je sais pas quels sont les hommes les
les origines deux des agresseurs mais je
crois qu'effectivement on s'aide dans
ces quartiers-là des quartiers
communautariser ghettoïser sont plus
propices à la violence et donc que la
première urgence est de contrôler les
flux migratoires vous par l'irs il faut
dire que à un moment
d'aucuns espéraient que la religion pas
si pire et ça ça n'a pas de sens c'est
vrai c'est vrai quand ils voient la
mosquée en général ils brûlent pas de
bagnole ses caisses pour moi il faut
être honnête et finalement ça n'a pas
donné les deux si excellent de six
excellents résultats
mais moi je vous demande j'ai
l'impression aussi que dans ces
quartiers par exemple pour il ya des
gamins ya parfois une vingtaine ou
dizaines
deux types de gamin je sais pas quel âge
ils ont qui fou qui font peur aux gens
qui exercent une espèce de pression
physique
est-ce qu'on peut pas quand même on
éloigne et est-ce qu'on peut pas un
moment est-ce qu'il suffit pas de dire
je viens est ce qu'on appelle dans notre
art sans parler de nouvelles lois tout
parce qu'on a pas que dans notre arsenal
quand même de quoi
souvent les gens dans les cités vous
dites ça vous dise où il ya quelques
familles où quelques types qui font
régner un climat dégueulasse et et quand
il quand ils font des victimes sur
victimes de se marrer donc c'est ça le
climat un peu de démission générale
si vous laissez là vraiment je trouve
que dans les années 50 je pense qu'on
sanctionner les profs qui était trop
laxiste l'époque dénonçons les sanctions
sont aujourd'hui toute personne qui les
ont très peur de faire preuve d'un excès
d'autorité parce que ça on n'a pas parlé
de la responsabilité des médias
mais honnêtement je pense que là dedans
si vous voulez il ya une espèce de etc
sandra parler des tabous de la question
surtout pas avoir l'air d'être raciste
on a jeté un voile pudique sur plein de
réaliser alors aujourd'hui une sorte de
prise de conscience
mais combien de temps ça va durer juste
un mot pour rebondir sur ce que tu
disais soit l'éloignement les danois qui
sont quand même pas des ultra
conservateurs ont voté de manière
consensuelle loire une loi anti gay taux
est justement de dos toute personne qui
est condamné qui habite dans une cité
n'a pas le droit de dire revenir les
habite et je pense que c'est une mesure
de bon sens même si effectivement ces
lois supplémentaires
alors arrêtons les réseaux sociaux nous
dit que ce soit que ce soit la sécurité
l'islam ou l'immigration il y à un déni
du gouvernement
tétanisés par la gauche frédéric dabi
est ce que les français font grief au
pouvoir de c2c
et c'est plus que des incidents de ces
événements dramatiques ou est-ce qu'en
gros il n'y en a pas la responsabilité
je pense que les français ne s'y habitue
pas et nous y habituerons jamais et donc
il ya très clairement une responsabilité
du
politique et un discours en termes en
fait d'impuissance le discours de gérard
collomb a lors de son lors de son départ
même si son départ a été saluée dans
fait les baromètres parce que les
adversaires temel macron dans nos bras
matiga demi pendant que leurs maîtres
il faut fiducial pour match ont apprécié
qui tordent le bras au président au delà
de ça son bilan n'a pas du tout été
saluée et ce type de discours de constat
alors qu'il avait les manettes si je
puis dire de la place beauvau n'est
absolument pas entendu par les français
les discours un peu fatah ni sur le
chômage on a tout essayé ça passait très
mal
les discours sur la question de la
sécurité qui est perçu la sécurité par
les français comme un droit inaliénable
et est un droit attaqué ne passera à mon
avis encore monde frédéric justement
mais vous ramener tout est simplement la
question de la sécurité mais dans le
discours de compte ça allait inscrire la
question du vivre ensemble
là je me rattacher au cdr un gamin de 10
ans était battu la sécurité n'a pas été
associée d'errance et que à la limite ça
aurait été un bon motif de rupture et
d'en obtenir le président ne veut pas
voir parce qu'elle 6 0 c'est qu'elle
nous dise ça sur le pas de la porte
jusque là on passe à un autre sujet est
ce que les juges ont trop d' influence
sur la vie politique et ce qu'ils
interfèrent à l'excès sur le calendrier
politique
il ya deux événements qui nous ont donné
envie de revenir sur ce sujet d'abord
vendredi dernier marine le pen a été
mise en examen pour une affaire de
détournement de fonds publics alors
c'est lié aux emplois présumés fictifs
du parlement européen elle avait déjà
été mis en examen pour abus de confiance
elle avait été aussi dans une autre
affaire
convoqué pour une expertise
psychiatrique le moins qu'on puisse dire
est que ça ne semble pas l'atteindre
trop elle dit même qu'elle rendra coup
pour coup écoutée elle était en corrèze
ce week-end c'est vrai que l'on voit
s'amonceler sur nous les bercy
sion avant c'était une par mois puis une
par semaine là en ce moment c'est une
par jour
alors encore une fois signal à tout le
monde et particulièrement à nos
adversaires ils n'arriveront pas à nous
intimider
alors deuxième élément à verser au
dossier pour écouter votre point de vue
françois bayrou était hier l'invité du
grand jury rtl le figaro lci peut-être
vous souvenez-vous qu'il était garde des
sceaux
quand edouard philippe a composé son
premier gouvernement il a dû partir au
bout de quelques semaines parce que il y
avait une enquête préliminaire qui avait
été ouverte là encore pour une affaire
d'emplois présumés fictifs au parlement
européen et puis depuis un an et demi il
se passe rien n'y a pas eu de mise en
examen est nouveau et du coup on lui a
posé la question ce que vous pensez que
il y avait des arrière pensées des juges
est ce que est ce qu'il y avait une
portée politique alors en gros il nous a
dit ben je peux pas vous répondre mais
quand même je n'en pense pas moins
regardez cette séquence qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que je vous dise que c'est
arrivé par hasard que vraiment il n'y a
eu dans cette affaire aucune sortes
d'interférences je me garde de porter un
jugement mais vous n'en pense une maman
ce je pense que le que le hasard fait
bien les choses
voilà vous ne pensez pas moi ce que je
me suis permis d'ajouter parce que ça
m'a semblé transparent
alexis poulain il est pas question
d'empêcher les juges de faire leur
travail simplement on se dit puis quand
ce genre d'affaires a autant d'impact on
peut penser par exemple la mise en
examen de françois fillon est ce qu'il
faudrait pas inventer des nouvelles
règles ou bien pour dire au juge pas
en période électorale vous intervenez
bois ou bien au sein du gouvernement de
dire ben tant qu'on n'est pas condamné
on n'a pas à démissionner parce que
sinon tout le monde démissionne
c'est quand même incroyable de se poser
cette question dire que les juges
devraient empêcher de faire leur travail
parce que des gens sont élus et donc il
sort l immunité
le belge d'immunité comme le président
d'ailleurs qui est le seul à l'avoir à
ce moment là parce qu'on a mis un peu
des nouvelles règles pour changer le jeu
politique
je crois qu'une des causes principales
de la montée du populisme c'est
l'absence de justice ses obsèques à
écrire un livre nous sommes pauvres nous
avons soif de justice
je crois que ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
le front national a autant de succès
salvini aussi arrivent en italie le
grand dégagisme qu'on peut voir c'est
qu'il ya une classe une caste où on a eu
ce discours du tous pourris et qui sait
année après année bien sûr année après
année qui s'est vérifiée vous avez des
gens vous avez une justice à deux
vitesses ça se voit quand vous avez un
puissant qui se fait rattraper par la
justice ça s'appelle de l'intimidation
non c'est la justice vous avez
d'ailleurs le cas de la violence vous
parliez du hip hop ce qu'il vous reste
quand même quelques noms mais solides
convictions de votre peine et encore
heureux mais il est attendu ce soir à
lille
le principe car ils jouent bas vous avez
pas besoin est élu vous êtes connu caris
booba vous foutez en l'air un aéroport
les jeunes regardent ça la rixe entre
les rues rentre alors environ 15 qui se
passe on a les attendait ça va coûter
des sous ils ont des concerts et cetera
panpan culcul bon 1 en sursis rentrez
chez vous il ya rien à voir
des gosses font ça mais ils se prennent
50 10 ans je sais pas combien parce
qu'il met on est on est encore c'est
vigipirate
je suis dans un environnement ouvert
pour de jeunes entrepreneurs pendant la
foire en faire beaucoup pour comprendre
dollar ne s'était pas primo délinquants
il n'était pas dans mes yeux
voilà sur la justice et les puissants
faut arrêter avec le fait que les juges
sont des harceleurs et qui empêche les
élus de faire leur travail bien au
contraire je pense qu'ils sont là pour
empêcher la montée des populismes il est
temps et regardez l'italie
vous avez eu la juste de faire pas du
tout non non c'est bien l'inversé je
pense que regardez l'italie où la mafia
avait le pouvoir des juges n'avaient pas
le pouvoir avait plus pouvoir de la
justice vous avez le pouvoir est avec la
france aux mains des mafias qui ne veut
pas passer l'air ne savait pas s'il
devait annoncer de dire si vous n'êtes
pas d'accord je ne veux pas que la
france soit aux mains des massifs tiens
je considère néanmoins que le pouvoir
des juges peut-être excessives les du
tout mais laissez moi vous expliquer je
vais devenir voulu dire c'est vrai je
pense que depuis plusieurs années sous
les tous les pouvoirs sont scrutés le
parlement les méchas etc
les juges les juges eux dès que vous
critiquez la justice vous est horrible
vous êtes un horrible adversaires de la
démocratie
or dans les deux cas pas dans les mains
dans les deux cas dans le cas de marine
le pen au moins je peux vous le dire moi
je suis convaincu si vous voulez que les
juges ont eu la main beaucoup plus
lourde
soul et qu'il ne l'aurait eue avec
françois bayrou par exemple qui n'a pas
sa première et vient entre non plus
deuxièmement secret de l'instruction si
vous voyez une alliance des juges des
journalistes s'ils voulaient qui depuis
qu'il fait des et qui déséquilibre
complètement le système donc moi je
trouve qu'il ya un risque de pouvoir des
juges qui veulent justement se payer des
puissants alors là on peut dire qu'ils
sont pas aux ordres mais regardez
regardez dans le cas le calendrier de la
paire fillon
si vous voulez me dites pas qu'il ya pas
une intervention de la justice mais
alexandre l'a certainement mais je le
trouverai exclu canadien à savoir
alexandre dyer
alors alex par me suis rendu compte que
j'avais trop parlé voilà
avec les juges gens font-ils trop contre
les politiques ont contre certains
politiques c'est ce que j'allais dire la
petite nuance c'est que j'ai
l'impression que il ya aussi une justice
à deux vitesses effectivement ou à l'air
de se plaindre mais l'enquêtre et bien
lente et dans la sphère fillon leur
enquête a été très très rapide
et aujourd'hui on se demande bien ce que
devient cette enquête donc des additions
à cette dernière où il ya une quinzaine
de jours quand même oui mais vous vous
en conviendrez
et puis deux poids deux mesures entre la
délinquance en col blanc justement et
les petits voyous qui pourrissent aussi
l'avis des français au quotidien
on l'a vu tout à l'heure et qui sont
relâchés dans la nature donc c'est
plutôt ça à mon avis aujourd'hui le
problème est en réalité il ya des juges
rouges on l'a vu avec le mur des cons il
faut dire il faut dire ce qui est en
fait moi ce qui m'amuse plus tôt là
dedans c'est les conséquences politiques
que cela va avoir parce que
effectivement si le but est d'empêcher
politiquement marine le pen à risque
quand même 10 ans d'inégibilité
finalement les juges vont faire à mon
avis le le jeu du conte du conservateur
puisque je crois que là la famille le
pen depuis des années à stérilise à
certains noms un certain pourcentage des
voix et fait le jeu du candidat du
système et si jamais les le pen était
avant avait écarté du pouvoir ça
créerait l'espace pour le coup pour un
grand parti conservateur et populaire
donc ce serait surtout une révolte
excuse moi chez les électeurs de marine
le pen que t'es pas prêt de nombreux
noms mais je mets donc ce serait
complètement j'avais ce sera la fin à un
scandale démocratique et à la fois
quelque chose qui me précipiterai une
recomposition bienvenues comme m lula en
prison comme maître l'her en prison mais
tout à fait mais justement est là le
problème est plus large possible mais là
c'est l'ancien président brésilien il ya
quand même aussi un coup d'état des
juges qui se mêlent de politique de
droit et à plus ample
partout là on en est pas là quand même
on va écouter je vous donne ma vie en
passant des internautes
babineau qui trouve que c'est plutôt
marine le pen qui instrumentalisent sa
situation judiciaire
en jouant la carte de la persécution et
yoann qui nous dit pourquoi ne parle
t'on plus de la sphère fillon et bien si
charles yoann on en parle et c'est un
point de vue justement émoi auprès des
rémois je voulais revenir ce que vient
de dire
alexis sur leurs gamins sur la
perception d'une justice inégalitaire où
à deux vitesses mais elle est
massivement partagé par les français il
faut pas fait toute une série d' enquête
pour le ministère pour le conseil
supérieur de la magistrature au moment
de la remise à des obligations
déontologiques à nicolas sarkozy avant
il ya maintenant quelques années mais
l'idée d'une justice pour les puissants
et donc dans ce cadre là les politiques
et marine le pen sont vus comme les
puissants donc ça ne fera pas pleurer
dans les chaumières une victime
elle n'est pas vue comme une victime
même si elle se cherche elle cherche et
c'est de bonne guerre son père faisait
ça cherche à se victimiser
rappelez vous une intervention télévisée
où il y avait commencé avec un avec un
bâillon autour autour de la tête
maintenant lorsqu'on travaille son image
des juges
c'est vrai qu'ils ont une image de
compétence d'experts 6 mais il ya un
point sur lequel l'opinion est beaucoup
plus suspicieux c est ce que les juges
sont indépendants du pouvoir économique
et du pouvoir politique et c'est vrai
que de ce point de vue là leur intrusion
dans une campagne en fait présidentiel
prenons la dernière ça avait fortement
choqué une partie du peuple de droite
cela n'avait pas empêché françois fillon
d'échouer aux portes du second tour à ma
peine 200 mille deux cent mille voix et
je pense que quand on interrogeait les
électeurs qu'ils étaient prêts à voter
pour françois fillon mais qui n'ont pas
fait ce ne sont pas des affaires qui ont
empêché de voter mais tout le brouillage
et tout le comment dire le l'incapacité
de françois fillon à pouvoir faire
campagne
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya un débat qui se
pose chez les français sur
l'indépendance de la justice du monde
politique vous pose la question sur
twitter 1
est ce que les juges ont trop d'
influence sur la vie politique et vous
nous avez répondu
c'est plutôt oui c'est vrai après 2 à
près des deux tiers
c'était évidemment pas un sondage
scientifique mais un point de vue qui
expriment les internautes que de
l'émission qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ma proposition
désormais on n'a plus besoin de
démissionner du gouvernement quand on
est mise en examen ou ou quoi tourner
vers la chambre a laissé point vous êtes
vous êtes plutôt contre vous j'imagine
oui pour vous il faut souvent des
consignes vu mon nom je pense qu'il faut
rendre des comptes mais après
effectivement il faut une justice qui a
les moyens qui égale qui traite tout le
monde à la même enseigne
il faut pas qu'ils aient un sentiment
d'un camp contre un autre qui est que
quand on soit coup sous le couvert d'une
enquête ce soit je pense que c'est
normal ne pas pouvoir exercer une
fonction publique parce qu'on est
concentré sur sa défense ça prend
beaucoup de temps quand on est sous
l'oeil de la justice de se défendre
donc si on veut faire son boulot de
ministre correctement on peut pas en
même temps il est frais il ya une
présomption d'innocence mais je parle là
d'un poste électif de la haute fonction
d'état je pense que c'est différent pour
le citoyen lambda
donc là il ya quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre la transparence qui est
nécessaire et qui doit dire d'abord
faisons levant le voile sur cette
affaire et puis on est dans les affaires
comme des affaires publiques quand vous
pourrez donc moi je trouve que c'est
plutôt bien d'arriver à dire attention
on ne pouvait pas en cause la prendre
sous licence ont dit vous pouvez pas
faire votre boulot si vous avez à vous
défendre en parallèle c'est compliqué
mais maintenant je voudrais dire que moi
sur les affaires sarkozy on remonte loin
non mais je vais très vite il ya un
paquet il ya eu l'affairé libyenne
oublions prenons juste celle lancée par
mediapart et qui est une sorte de
feuilleton au pour l'instant gros son de
financement parallèle volant du col d'el
qods on est encore là longtemps
excusez moi pour l'instant ça fait quand
même des années que ça dure ça nourrit
régulièrement la chronique et qui a des
auditions alors c'était dans la paire de
financement lumière quand il a été
révélé
auditions et cetera et cetera et au se
dissout les là il ya une espèce de
d'alliance de sainte alliance entre les
juges et les journalistes donc c'est
l'alliance du bien plus personne là
c'est en l'occurrence médiapart évident
des juges qui travaillent main dans la
main même pas le cacher mais on a les
dossiers
on a les dossiers si vous voulez on live
à peu près on a des pv des extraits des
pv en live donc donc à la fin ce que je
me dise voulait comme ça aura duré très
longtemps c'est un peu comme les types
qui ont attendu l'autobus six mois comme
d'hab attendu une heure vous n'avez pas
envie de vous barrer et ben en fait si à
la fin c'est à dire moi je me demande si
les juges qu'ils vont juger pour juger
vraiment sereinement ou s'ils ne vont
pas être amené si vous voulez à dire et
pourquoi même qu'à la fin de tout ça il
ya quand même un petit quelque chose
parce que ça fait dix ans qu'on emmerde
les français avec ce feuilleton
non mais je vous assure et je voulais
dire que nous les français qui pensent
comme l'a dit frédéric et bien je veux
je le redis très affectueusement à mon
avis se trompent parce qu'aujourd'hui le
s'il ya un pouvoir exorbitant des juges
il s'exerce d'abord à l'égard des
puissants il a pour le coup c'est un peu
tout et je sa moisson vernis la
transparence quand même et sur la terre
ferme donc moi je suis comme comme toi
je suis pour la le respect de la
présomption d'innocence mais quand même
quand on donne la richard faire enrichir
fédération nationale au président de
l'assemblée nationale et avec ça c'est
un cas d'enrichissement personnel
il ya quand même une enquête qui est
faite sur lui quand on a donné autant de
leçons
est ce que il est légitime de nommer
fallait pas été nommé l'été élus mais le
président a fait en sorte qu'il soit élu
au perchoir est ce que est ce que c'est
très légitime
il ya quand même une hypocrisie un deux
poids deux mesures là dessus et pour
bayrou c'est pareil c'est vraiment la
phrase de bossuet dieu se rit des gens
qui déplore les conséquences dont ils
chérissent les causes pareil ça a été un
chantre de la transparence de la morale
politique à la santé
denis caniza roseraie amusant
l'assemblée reste on dit peut-être
avez-vous suivi cette intervention
courte mais remarquée d'un député de la
france est soumise françois ruffin pour
ne pas le nommer
c'était jeudi dernier il s'était
violemment pris à partie il a par don ou
violemment pris à parti les députés dans
marche qui refusait sa proposition en
gros de dette supplémentaire pour les
enfants handicapés à l'école
et voilà ce qu'il leur a dit vous n'avez
pas honte honte de votre paresse contre
de votre sectarisme
vous n'avez même pas participé aux
échanges vous êtes contenté en groupe en
troupeau de voter contre
quand content content devenez levé la
main en cadence comme des playmobil les
noms des votants seront publiques
je les publierai sur ma page facebook et
je serai pas le seul
ils circuleront à travers la france et
ce vote
ce vote j'en suis convaincu ce vote vous
collera à la peau comme une infamie
voilà il proposait qu'il y ait davantage
de ce qu'on appelle des assistantes de
vie scolaire des avs pour aider ses
enfants
en fait il avait bien organisé se
intervention françois ruffin et ils sont
les t'expliquer sur sa chaîne youtube
c'était ce week-end en disant de toute
façon à l'assemblée on n'a pas
d'influencé sur les lois parce qu'elles
sont déjà décidées et déjà voté par le
gouvernement une fois qu'elle arrive
chez nous donc on peut s'en servir que
comme une tribune
écoutez le comment tu vas la faire
passer ta colère ou est ce qu'elle va
être la fenêtre de tir
comment tu vas utiliser tes deux minutes
ça se prépare quelque chose comme ça moi
je suis un animateur de la démocratie
c'est pas vrai le travail législatif je
sais que sa brusque que de dire ça mais
c'est de la foutaise
bah oui la preuve c'est dire ils sont
300 donc c'est pas ça c'est qu'on a là
une tribune pour venir animer la
démocratie c'est une tribune parmi
d'autres les médias c'est une autre
tribu les meetings c'est une tribune
famille c'est assez recevable je trouve
en tout cas c'est mon point de vue
cette cette argumentation de françois
ruffin disant de toute façon c'est le
gouvernement qui décide des lois celles
qui préparent les projets ils bloquent
les amendements donc on peut qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire
on peut crier c'est tout ce qui nous
reste à l'assemblée surtout quand on est
fait partie d'un groupe d'opposition
avec moins de vingt députés c'est très
difficile de faire passer des choses
c'est vrai qu'il en est sur une
stratégie du coup d'éclat permanent une
stratégie c'est la stratégie du groupe
des insoumis de essayé on avait vu avec
le avec les 5 euros d'apl avec les
victuailles qui avait été rapporté
qu'est-ce qu'on peut s'acheter avec avec
25 euros c'est vrai aussi
et ça limite peut-être l'éclat les
éclats de françois ruffin il faut dire
ce qui est dans notre régime
présidentiel la scène parlementaire
n'est pas une scène visible par les
françaises systématiquement quand on
travaille sur des événements cela sur la
mémorisation d'événements qui ont eu
lieu à l'assemblée peut-être à
l'exception c'est l'année du discours de
manuel valls et après les 11 janvier ils
sont très faiblement mémorisées ouais il
y avait aussi la sphère du maillot de
foot pour le sport amateur c'est
vraiment la stratégie
françois ruffin qui parle de sujets du
terrain pour essayer de les planter dans
ce match je vous dise et peu efficace
qu'avec un efficace parce qu'elles
fassent pas bien dans l'opinion rosanna
sont peu ça parce que c'est pas du jeu
pense que ce qu'il a faire vu la raison
non mais je dis pas qu'il est enfin je
dis que c'est très difficile de faire
passer son message auprès des français
même si la question du handicap c'est
une question qui touche énormément
les français est très et plus on est
concentrés ou plutôt concerné par la
question du handicap plus il ya un
sentiment de colère absolument terrible
vis-à-vis de l'action des pouvoirs
publics et de ce gouvernement
voilà même si après le gouvenement
répondu qu'ils faisaient déjà des choses
mais ça on n'entre pas sur le fond du
dossier
c'était plutôt cette attitude est elle
même à l'action d'envergure qu'est ce
que vous en pensez par exemple quand la
députée de la france un soumise au
moment du départ de manuel valls à agite
d'aider des panneaux sur lesquels elle
était création débarras vous trouvez que
cette expression il y aurait beaucoup à
dire sur la désertion de manuel valls
mais je trouve que c'était pas pour le
coup ce n'était pas très très élégant
mais bon moi ça ne me ça me choque pas
au contrat je pense que ça fait partie
de
toujours en fait du rôle du député dans
représentation nationale car
représentation donc ils font un travail
représentatif ils portent des sujets sur
la table c'est le cas avec le handicap
ça a permis de mettre en lumière un
sujet important donc je trouve que rufin
féfé fait son travail comme on le fait
en fait depuis depuis la révolution
française
alors après si c'est pas un orateur
formidable je trouvais les s asseyent
mais au moins il a il a l'énergie eni va
et on pourrait presque regretter que le
front national qui pourrait être cette
voie des classes populaires à
l'intérieur de l'assemblée nationale va
se servent finalement assez peu de cette
tribune ne pas les mots france éloquence
à l'assemblée alexandre vient de le
rappeler
ça n'est pas tout à fait une nouveauté
le problème justement c'est éloquent
s'abaissait éclos niveau séoul et je
pense qu'il ya eu dans les années 20
dans les années trente à l'assemblée
nationale je pense qu'il ya eu vraiment
des peu des passes d'armes des joutes
oratoires qui devrait être de beaux
morceaux
je pense que sur la convention dans la
convention dans la constitution dans les
assemblées de la révolution qu'est ce
que c'est quand même il ya des discours
de l'homme de l'art et conditions qui
sont tout à fait autre chose que ça le
problème de ruffalo
effectivement on peut comprendre tout ce
que vous avez dit il me semble
d'ailleurs se trouve que ce sont de bons
arguments que vous avez cités sur l'idée
du parlement comme une tribune je trouve
c'est assez convaincante le problème
c'est que sur le fond de son
argumentation j'ai les noms et lui il
est resté coincé même pas à robespierre
mais à robespierre en bande dessinée
mais c'est un peu j'ai les noms je vais
je vais les ressortir des donc moi oui
puisque la trouille alors qu'enfin il
faisait prix thomas rey il est des films
drôles son nouveau genre commissaire du
peuple m'inquiète un peu
les noms sont publics de toute façon sur
les voyages avec l'inde application vous
allez le chercher
donc c'est rigolo de le faire comme ça
en disant voilà mais effectivement il se
met en scène comme tout le monde c'est
une mise en scène l'assemblée nationale
c'est la mise en scène du pouvoir de la
fabrique des lois ce qu'ils disent sur
le fond est vrai c'est à dire que qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire dans le débat
quand on a une assemblée aux ordres qui
sert à rien les lois arrivent elles sont
écrites ça s'appelle une majorité
damages invité un peu plus houleuses par
les enfants soient landes mais là on est
sur une majorité vraiment de merka la
mer calme les lois sont même jusqu'à
être écrite révisé revue par les lobbies
rappelez-vous sur le glyphosate ou s'est
passé par le cabinet du ministre ça
c'est un scandale d'état
on a très peu parlé non mais c'est un
scandale d'état et france et ils ont ils
mesuré loi dans les cabinets des
ministres avec les lobbys pour les faire
signer rsa gré par la compagnie ce que
les français savent pas trop ce qui se
passe à l'assemblée mais en revanche ça
alors il juste après le départ de
nicolas hulot il ya une chute de
popularité des manuels macro et quand on
interrogeait qualitativement les
français c'était moins de départ de
nicolas hulot mais d'une part que le
gouvernement
relégué la question environnementale au
second plan et que c'est un gouvernement
qui cédait au lobby et dans ce cadre là
le glyphosate était très fortement cité
s'est pas passée à l'as et faire des
coups d'éclat oui ça permet aussi de
mettre des sujets parce que derrière la
majorité est obligé de s'expliquer que
faites-vous finalement solange majorité
heures
vous réagissez en commission que chaque
comme sur chacun des sujets traités
aujourd'hui va-t-on vers un article
permanent vous nous répondez oui à ont
quasiment aux trois quarts quelques
commentaires turin goûtu turing innodis
est un opposant professionnel il parle
évidemment de françois ruffin alors que
baby ne revient sur le le fond du sujet
c'est à dire celui des assistantes de
vie scolaire en 10 ans ce qui est
inquiétant c'est le manque de
contradictions flagrant au sein de la
république en marche oui oui
effectivement ils sont assez silencieux
ce qui amplifie l'intervention de rufin
frédéric dabi kankan à votre avis les
français voient des députés qui ont des
pancartes bon débarras pour saluer le
départ de manuel valls
les gens disent basse et de l'expression
normale où il trouve que c'est un peu
infantile ou manque de respect j'ai peur
je je pense que ça a été
c'est relativement inconvenant et ça
manque complètement d'élégance même si
ça intéressant de voir je parlais de la
remontée de popularité très forte de
gérard collomb après son départ dans le
même temps les français ont entre
guillemets sanctionner le départ de
manuel valls pour la ville de barcelone
puisqu'il a reculé de quasiment 7 ne
veulent pas aller hulot de partir comme
un malpropre donc l'attention des
parlementaires et ne veulent pas que
l'on menace de partir santé nous avons
chanté la république quand même c'est
l'addition d'un sommet juste un mot
basque ce qui est inquiétant je trouve
et c'est en fait c'est ça qui m'a gêné
j'ai pas répondu tout à l'heure c'est
que je pense que la haine des insoumis
pour manuel valls est quand même
suspecte et qui sortent sur un certain
nombre de passions tristes d'une partie
de leur électorat et là il ya il ya il
ya une dérive à mon avis communautariste
pour aller draguer chez des
antisionistes pour le dire poliment 6 me
qui me dérange leurs amis c'est un sujet
passionnant mais c'est pas sûr
d'aujourd'hui est ce que la ligue live
est-ce que la ligne laïque de manuel
valls
et alors c'est le personnage de manga
mal de gens qu'ils pensaient c'est très
bien alors pourquoi c'est comme ça c'est
parfait vous avez tous pu exprimer votre
point de vue nous reste quelques minutes
pour parler de cette initiative d'anne
hidalgo maire de paris qui a annoncé
qu'elle allait accueillir une
cinquantaine des sdf de femmes au sein
des salons de l'hôtel de ville de paris
est ce que c'est une bonne idée on sait
qu'il ya de très nombreux sdf dans paris
on les on les estime entre 5 et 10 mille
écouter un avis assez critique mais
c'est pour lancer le débat c'est celui
de bernard debré il est conseillé les
républicains au conseil de paris et il
était invité hier chez nos confrères de
bfm tv
alors comment mettre aussi à matignon à
l'elysée
et pourquoi pas aux missions à
l'intérieur il ya personne pour
l'instant on ne pourrait peut-être en
mettre
je trouve ça totalement démagogique et
en plus le résultat d'une faillite
alexis paulin c'est de la démagogie ou
c'est une belle initiative non c'est de
la démagogie enfin on va bien classe
c'est vraiment un message de comme paul
de communication politique présent
pourquoi accueillir dans un espace qui
n'est pas prévu pour ça alors que la
mairie de paris à des espaces où qui
pourrait davantage adapté que dire on va
sous les ors de la république m 50
femmes sdf
le message c'est dans les salons assez
solennel avec des amis
c'est à la fois insultant pour ces
personnes là qui mérite un accueil de
qualité et aussi de dire mais pourquoi
on en arrive là
si vous voulez accueillir correctement
des sdf vous avez vous plusieurs moyens
de le faire avec des associations qui
militent pour ça vous avez la fondation
abbé-pierre vous avez jeudi noir qui
essayent de réquisitionner des locaux
vides dans paris vous avez la mairie qui
a des locaux vous pouvez aussi
travailler avec les entreprises les
entreprises ont des espaces vides et
pourquoi pas dans le cadre de la rse
dire bah écoutez si vous accueillez des
sdf c'est toujours ça de pris et vous
aurez je sais pas quelle est donc un
match aller on peut faire dans la
citation
là c'est vraiment pour la photo c'est
pour l'image je trouve que c'est
dommageable c'est bien aussi ça permet
de poser le problème au coeur de la
table mais c'est pas de l'action
publique c'est de la com public et il va
falloir rentrer maintenant dans l'action
parce que l'hiver arrive et que chaque
hiver c'est la même chose on aura des
morts dans les rues de paris
on aura jamais assez de place de lee
vous pouvez aller voir au samu social la
galère que c'est pour faire les maraudes
pour retrouver des places chaque soir
moi je les fais
et c'est voilà donner des moyens au samu
social
arrêtez de faire de la com paul sur un
sujet grave comme celui ci frédéric dabi
pensez vous que les français sont aussi
sévère qu'avec six poulains sur cette
initiative
les parisiens ne se complètement moins
que les français mais comme vous comme
vous le disiez ça le mérite de parler
d'un enjeu d'une question qui n'est
jamais pris en charge pas très peu pris
en charge par les par les pouvoirs
publics
je me souviens d'un hiver très rigoureux
il ya deux trois ans et il a fallu a en
fait attendre une intervention de sylvia
pinel le 31 décembre sur une radio pour
que le gouvernement de l'époque parle
la question des sdf alors fait bien sûr
anne hidalgo et de toute façon perdante
puisque on dira que 55 me ça ne vaut
rien et que s'il ya une dimension de
communication politique tout cela aussi
qu'est ce qui choque c'est le fait
qu'elles prennent en charge ce
dossier même si c'est vrai qu'elle parle
à son électorat hulu la question du
statut d'un hôtel de ville je connais un
peu ce qui se passe dans des hôtels de
ville comme à vienne femme unique et ce
ne sont pas des forteresses tout l'été à
vienne
les hôtels de ville accueille des
enfants en difficulté qui sont en fin de
garde et donc je trouve que bien sûr il
ya une dimension de symbole politique
mais voilà entre ne rien faire ne rien
dire et annoncer ça peut être que des
parisiens seront un petit peu moins
c'est lors que vous avez vous alexandre
ii vecchio mais c'est vrai je pense que
anne hidalgo a craqué quoi elles nous
ont fait une chaque semaine à un jour
c'est les passages piétons multicolores
l'autre les huîtres autoire donc on voit
une espèce de panique chez elle vous
avez là on dise manquer le délire
beaubourg absolue et donc on voit bien
qu'elle appelle qu'elle a perdu la main
y compris je crois chez cet électorat
bobo qui n'en peut plus parce que paris
est sale et effectivement il ya la
question des sdf qui est une vraie
question est donc elle tente un coup de
plus mais voilà ça fait penser à une fin
d'une fin de règne quoi qui est qui et
qui est tragi comique mais après la
question de des sdf est très importante
et c'est vrai que pour habiter paris je
trouve ça insupportable pour voyager un
peu je pense qu'il ya que dans notre
pays que il ya autant de sdf comme ça
dans les grandes villes dont l état de
berlin met donc dans l'europe du sud par
exemple paradoxalement où il ya où il ya
une crise plus forte que la nôtre il ya
des solidarités aussi sans doute
familiale il ya je sais pas je sais pas
pourquoi mais il ya beaucoup de grandes
villes que j'ai pu faire où il n'y a pas
cette situation et on a l'impression que
c'est quand même très très nette
progression c'est absolument scandalisée
par ce cynisme compassionnel non mais
alexis l'a très bien dit elle nous dit
qu'elle va devoir trouver 1000 et 500
places elle demande à l'état d'en
trouver la moitié donc elle va affecter
qu'elle fric pour rénover ces deux alors
un des salons étaient pour les
expositions et l'autre pour les
réceptions c'est là qu'on a reçu la
reine dont le
m le message c'est quoi c'est qu'il faut
sacrifier que l'on en est au point que
la france cinquième puissance mondiale
doit choisir entre les arts et la pas
rage entre les arts la diplomatie la
parra et le social c'est du foutage de
gueule c'est dégueulasse
la deuxième raison pour laquelle c'est
dégueulasse c'est que très bien elle
nous dit je suis d'accord il doit y
avoir un problème spécifique des femmes
sdf puisque même si elles ne sont que
12% du total
à l'évidence des risques différents et
plus grand je viens en attente le bon
sens permet de le comprendre on n'a pas
besoin de ces tanks donc qui est un
accueil spécifique très bien mais que
nous dit-elle en plus dans son fantasme
d'un monde des livres et du mal si vous
voulez c'est que pour les mettre à
l'aise
elles ne seront prises en charge que il
faut dire il faut être délicat faut les
mettre à l'aise et donc il n'y aura que
des femmes et cette idée si vous voulez
ma mission c'est pas du tout leurs le
coeur de leurs trucs mais c'est
inconscient cette idée si vous voulez
que les femmes ne sont en sécurité et
que est à l'aise moi c'est la non mixité
qui met mal à l'aise vous voyez des
tracks avait que des femmes ça me met
très mal à l'aise non mais là je blague
je veux tu transmettre aux éditions pas
manqué d expérience violences dans le
centre d'hébergement mais c'est donc
dans l'hébergement soit non mixtes pas
du tout ce que je dis simplement l'idée
de les entourer général exclusivement
féminin si vous voulez dans l'idée que
c'est ça qui va leur redonner confiance
en elle je trouve ça révèle qu'un petit
quelque chose de sa vision du monde
enfin la rue ça abîme énormément et
c'est vrai que d'avoir des femmes qui
vont vous prendre en charge mais aussi
vous aider à vous maquiller à vous
reprendre ça c'est extrêmement important
dans la dans la sortie de la rue donc
c'est pas c'est pas une mauvaise idée
d'être entre femmes pour reprendre
confiance en soi et repartir là dessus
ce panneau réside peut-être je venais
pas je dois vous dire je m'en fous je me
je dois me fier à votre connaissance du
sujet qui est plus grande que la mienne
on pense mais il talgo par contre d'une
démagogie je vous assure une rose
il faudrait savoir combien de l'argent
de combien de places d'hébergement
elle va des pâtes dépensés pour mettre
ces vous connaissez vous êtes déjà allé
à l'hôtel de ville c'est là il ya le
prix n'a ici télé truc comme ça c'est
des trucs énormes
un show fable etc vous allez remettre
des sanitaires combien de traits qu'elle
va dépenser pour pouvoir emmener des
caméras là si vous voulez franchement
c'est du cynisme on reviendra sur ce
sujet à de la grande nouveauté ce sera
demain dans les décrypteurs une autre
émission du figaro live on laisse le
dernier mot aux internautes
d'abord à l'un de ceux qui suivent
l'émission babineau qui le dit c'est
mieux que rien on reproche souvent à la
mairie de négliger les sdf au profit des
migrants point d'exclamation et puis de
la poser la question sur lefigaro.fr
c'était hier
est ce une bonne initiative d'ouvrir
l'hôtel de ville de paris aux sans abri
et vous étiez une majorité à nous
répondre non sur encore une fois ce qui
n'est pas un sondage mais il ya quand
même plus de 57 milles personnes qui ont
répondu voilà point de vue c'est fini
pour ce soir merci de nous avoir suivis
merci à nos quatre invités et nous
revenons demain à la même heure au même
endroit bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]
ce